Stephen Chase is an assistant professor
in the center for the neural basis of
cognition and the department of
biomedical engineering he will be
talking to us about motor control motor
learning and brain computer interfaces
thank you very much it's an honor to be
here I want to talk to you today about
the hardest thing you'll ever do and
contrary to popular belief the hardest
thing you'll ever do is not to endure
four years of a Pittsburgh winter the
hardest thing you'll ever do is move
walking on two feet upright is
incredibly difficult doing this this is
an incredibly complex task doing it with
your eyes closed it's insanely complex
this is why policemen will use this test
to see if you've been drinking because
it is one of the skills the first skills
that you lose when you're mildly
impaired we know it's hard because it
takes us forever to get any good at it
the girl in the pink stripes there is my
daughter she's 19 months old and she's
the light of my life but I will be
honest with you for the first six months
of her life from a motor control
perspective completely useless all she
could do is flail you give an infant a
pile of Cheerios
they will gleefully take those Cheerios
and scoop them up and drop them on the
ground for the dog to eat and scoop them
up occasionally one will get into the
mouth and they'll do this for hours and
will do this for hours because it takes
hours upon hours upon hours of practice
to use these the most complex tools
we've ever had to use we know motor
control is hard because we will pay
millions of dollars to those of us who
do it marginally better than others of
us for the sheer joy of watching them
perform and finally we know motor
control is hard because you devote more
neural real estate to the problem of
motor control than you do to most
anything else in addition to primary
motor cortex which as the name implies
ought to be the area that controls sends
direct control of her muscles there are
at last count six other cortical areas
all of which sent projections down the
spinal cord to exert direct
control of your muscles subcortical e we
have loops from the thalamus in the
basal ganglia which you may have heard
of from Parkinson's disease that all
engage in the process of motor control
and the cerebellum which is the size
structure that sits in the back of your
head it has more neurons in it and the
rest of the brain combined and the
primary role of the cerebellum is to
solve motor control problems you may ask
yourself why is motor control so hard
and the reason is because we're made out
of meat computers have silicon and gold
wires they can shuttle electrical pulses
around at about half the speed of light
it takes a visual stimulus from the time
it hits our retina until the time it can
act on motor control centers about 1/10
of a second
now a tenth of a second may not seem
very long but a tenth of a second is
time for a well struck tennis ball to
travel a good eight feet a tenth of a
second is the difference between being
an apex predator and being lion food the
tenth of a second is an age in motor
control so to overcome the burden of
working with a pile of meat we have to
learn the way we control we compensate
for these sensory motor delays as we
practice as we pick up these Cheerios
what we're doing is we're building a
conceptual internal model of our hand
we're predicting how our hand is going
to respond to those motor control pulses
and predicting where it's going to end
up in real time so that we can use that
information to make new motor control
decisions now these internal
representations of our limbs have to be
continually updated as we age as we can
injured as we fatigue every time we pick
up a new object we need a new model so
that we can perform dexterous motor
control with that and the biggest trick
your brain ever played on you was in
convincing you that motor control is
easy we don't even think about motor
control until it goes wrong spinal cord
injury affects roughly 300,000 people in
the United States roughly 12,000 new
cases per year the median age of spinal
cord injury is about 40 this represents
it tremendous burden on our healthcare
system
in addition to spinal cord injury other
motor control disorders like Lou
Gehrig's disease or ALS amputation brain
stem stroke Parkinson's disease all of
these represent disorders of motor
control where people can no longer move
in the way that they used to move in the
majority of these cases the cortical
representation of movement is intact the
problem represents a communication with
the muscles for whatever reason we can't
communicate with the muscles my research
involves trying to fix this this is a
video from colleagues of mine in the
Schwartz lab this is Jan Jan was roughly
30 when she suffered from a rare spinal
cerebellar to sort a distant disorder
which causes her lose the ability to
control all four of her limbs Jan has
two electrode recording arrays implanted
into the motor control centers of her
brain and we're using these control
signals to control the she's using these
these electrodes to control this robotic
arm and move it around and feed herself
chocolate for the first time in 10 years
what you may not know about brain
machine interfaces is that learning is
absolutely key to their success and also
learning appears to be one of the
reasons why they don't look better the
way these devices work is we record
signals directly from the motor control
areas of brain we tap out the electrical
impulses and we use those to directly
actuate a device in my case it's
typically cursors on computer screens
and I watch as subjects attempt to
control their neural activity to make
that cursor do what they want hit hit
targets get rewards brain computer
interfaces represent a tremendous tool
for studying motor learning because we
know exactly how they work we've
engineered them we don't know how hands
work we didn't engineer those but
because we know how these work we can
watch as subjects work to try and get
control of them and build internal
conceptualizations of these devices it
turns out subjects who use brain
computer interfaces can engage most of
the natural motor learning processes
that we engage most not all and we're
studying this process to try and
understand the development of these
internal models where they might go
wrong how we might be able to develop
them better as they struggle with a
cursor and are continually updating
those internal models we're trying to
refine how we send feedback to these
subjects so that they can learn faster
we're trying to push the fundamental
capacities of the brain how much can we
learn in a chunk of neural tissue and
how do we learn it our research
endeavors I consider them to be sort of
uniquely CMU we take we combine
techniques from machine learning
computer science engineering and we
combine them with neuroscience and
psychology biology and Carnegie Mellon
has been tremendously supportive in this
endeavor bringing it all under one roof
under the center for the neural basis of
cognition and brain head and putting it
all together thank you very much for
your attention
you